for nearly a century a statue of
Confederate General Robert E Lee stood
in Charlottesville Virginia in 1997 it
was listed on the national register of
historic places which meant that at the
time and this again was in the 90s so
not all that long ago it was considered
worthy of preservation for both its its
historical significance and its artistic
value a little over 20 years later in
the midst of public hysteria over the
overdose death of a criminal drug addict
in Minneapolis that 100-year-old work of
art which was supposed to be preserved
was instead torn down and we were told
moved to a museum well last week the
museum in a symbolic humiliation ritual
melted the statue down and destroyed it
it will now be repurposed as an
inclusive Arts display this is how we
treat our art and our historic monuments
these days it's especially how we treat
historical figures like Robert E Lee but
it wasn't always this way going back now
to the early to mid 19th century for
more than three decades during the that
span Robert El Le served as an officer
in the US military he graduated from
West Point went on to play a key role in
the Mexican-American War which is a war
that it isn't talked about very much
these days even though it it changed the
country forever and at the end of it
Mexico seated a lot of territory
including California Utah Nevada a lot
of what we now call Arizona New Mexico
and Colorado and Lee's role in that
Victory earned him a series of major Pro
Promotions he was eventually named the
superintendent of West Point which was
the military academy he once attended
just a few years after Lee left that
post the state of Virginia where Lee was
born seceded from the Union and at that
point Lee had a decision to make okay he
could accept a post with the Union Army
leading the Union Army in fact which was
offered to him by by Lincoln or he could
defend his home state which and and and
you know if if he decided to uh to take
the other option and to join the union
then he would be marching against his
state State his community his family
even his own Sons it would mean taking
up the sword against his own family now
even though Lee was no great fan of
either slavery or the idea of secession
he chose to defend his State and his
family instead in the end he felt a
greater loyalty to his State and to his
community and to his family than he did
to the federal government and back in
those days that's how a lot of people
felt he resigned from the US military
joined the Confederacy and won some of
the most battles of the war often when
he was up against very long odds after
the war Lee became a college professor
and he worked to unify the North and
South until his death he was remembered
across political lines for many many
decades as both an ingenious uh
tactician and a man of principle and
Faith Churchill called him one of the
best Generals in history Dwight D
Eisenhower the president of United
States and former commander of Allied
Forces in Europe during World War II had
this to say about Robert El Le
listen I think they good many of you
people here both photographers and and
representativ of the press have been
going into my office for the past 4 and
a half years
occasionally no doubt you've noticed
that on the wall there are the prince of
four men men that I considered in my
book are uh about the four top Americans
of the past they are Franklin Washington
Lincoln and Lee and anybody whoever
tries to put me in any other uh
relationship with respect to General Lee
is
mistaken now a few years later a dentist
wrote to isenhower and wrote a letter
demanding to know why he had that
picture of Roberty Lee in his office and
this is part of Eisenhower's response he
said quote he believed unswervingly in
the Constitutional validity of his cause
which until 1865 was still an arguable
question in America he was a poised and
inspiring leader from Deep conviction I
simply say a nation of men of Lee's
caliber would be Inc conquerable in
spirit and
soul now for the next few decades most
Americans agreed with that assessment in
the 9s we had movies venerating Robert E
Lee starring Martin Sheen and nobody
lost their minds over it the Lee statue
and statues like it stood in town
squares all over the country especially
in the South it wasn't an issue they
weren't vandalized there were no Angry
mobs demanding their
removal most people including those who
certainly cannot be described as
Confederate sympathizers recognize that
the Civil War was fought at a different
time in a different era and there were
noble men on either
side that's how most people viewed it
for decades and decades but somewhere
along the line just the past few years
everything changed statues of Roberty
Lee and anyone like him had to come down
we were told they had to come down right
away okay there was no time to talk
about it there was no time to debate you
weren't allowed to debate in fact you
weren't even allowed to uh to to express
any of the
viewpoints that nearly everyone held for
a hundred years before that these
statues were not a problem for a hundred
years but in the last 100 seconds they
became a problem and it was our duty to
Simply watch as they were all toppled
and carried away now already if you're a
perceptive and insightful person you
might ask yourself was this a sign of
progress like was this a good sign when
we started going around and had angry
mobs tearing down all these statues that
had been there for century and nobody
complained and then all of a sudden we
had to take them is this was this a sign
that that things were heading in a good
direction in our country were we a
better country back when a man like
Robert E Lee was widely respected or
will we a better country when we decided
that we could not have any
acknowledgement of him in any public
place which version of the country was
better which version of the country had
greater racial Harmony was it the one
back in the 90s when Robert E Lee
statues were being preserved as historic
monuments or the one in the
2020s what do you think now to make the
contrast even more clear the media did
not Elevate voices as articulate as
Churchill or Eisenhower to make the case
against the Robert ele
monuments instead they thrust BLM
activists like Zana Bryant in our faces
and uh here was her argument this is
from two years ago talking about this
same Monument here's what she said Z I
know you've heard this argument before
um I'm hoping that you could go ahead
and tell critics who feel like removing
the statue is is whitewashing history
and a section of our history that we
should be engaging with um and and by
removing it we're we're acting as though
uh it didn't happen or or we're trying
to erase a section of our history what
do you say to those folks I would say
actually erecting these monuments is
whitewashing our history um at the time
of emancipation Charlottesville and the
surrounding area was majority black and
you don't see that narrative by having
Confederate monuments standing in the
center of parks towering over whole
communities what you see is you see a
romanticized version of the South you
see um memorabilia that makes people
feel good about the Civil War but it
doesn't tell the story of the South
losing it doesn't tell the story of the
Confederacy falling um and so I think
that we cannot erase history we can't
edit it um in fact history already
happens so people can Google people can
use textbooks there are many other
resources there are whole museums that
teach people um about those legacies and
about the history of what happened here
um but what I think we're doing with
removing these statutes is we're no
longer offering a platform for white
supremacy and I think that by
deplatforming um and decentering those
harmful narratives um that perpetuate
violence and that perpetuate oppression
um is one of the most powerful things
that we can
do my Lord so again ask yourself are we
a better country when people like that
when their arguments are prevailing or
when you know when when we're uh
listening to Dwight de Eisenhower and
Churchill and those guys um she says the
monument was supposed to make people
feel good about the Civil War what is
that what you think monuments are meant
to do nobody feels good about about the
Civil War what do you mean feels good
about it would would have you ever heard
that opinion expressed what do you think
about the Civil War oh yeah I felt great
about it I feel really great I'm happy
so I feel good that doesn't even make
any sense okay monuments don't exist to
make us feel good about uh the wars that
they are
remembering but they do exist to
remember because these are events that
we should remember people always say
happy dog happy life well if that's
really the case you need to be giving
your dog rough greens naturopathic Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America before I started
feeding my dog Ruff greens I had no idea
that dog food is dead food it contains
very little nutritional value think
about it nutrition isn't Brown it's
green let rough greens bring your dog's
food back to life rough greens is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are wheat and that goes for dogs
too naturopathic Dr Dennis black is so
confident Ru greens will improve your
dog's health he's offering my listeners
a free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try it get a free jump start trial
bag delivered straight to your door in
just a few business days go to Ru
greens.com or call 844 ru700 that's
rfffg greens.com matat or call 844 Ru
today now first of all if Z Bryant looks
familiar and she does have a distinctive
look we must admit that's because uh
you've probably seen her before on this
show Brian is the morbidly obese BLM
activist who's officially sponsored by
Dove which is supposedly a brand that
promotes personal health and beauty but
obviously doesn't anymore Bryant became
famous for destroying the life of a
University of Virginia student with a
false accusation of racism so that's the
person that we're Consulting on on
issues like this but for a second let's
put aside what a horrible person Z Brant
is let's listen to the argument again
that she was making two years ago on
behalf of BLM she's supposedly not
objecting to the existence of the Statue
of Robert Lee at least not explicitly
instead she's saying that it doesn't
belong in a prominent public place that
it shouldn't stand in the center of
parks towering over whole communities
she insists that there are quote Whole
museums that people can go to if they
want to see statues like this one maybe
people can even Google pictures of the
statue if they're so
inclined now whatever the case the argu
arent was that uh BLM isn't trying to
erase history or denigrate this nation's
heroes or mock white people for honoring
one of the most brilliant Generals in
the history of the country no they're
not doing any of that they're just
trying to put everything in its proper
historical context the Lee statue
doesn't tell the story of the
Confederacy failing she complains as if
the role of a statue is to explain 19th
century history in
detail um there were a lot of black
people in Virginia she goes on to say
and and Lee was not black and therefore
this statue needs to come down and go to
a museum where it
belongs now none of that made any sense
at the time unless of course the goal
was never to move the statue of Robert E
Lee but instead to destroy it entirely
if that was the intent then everything
just went according to plan as I said at
the top activists and University faculty
members with the help of local
legislators just melted down the statue
of Robert El Lee in secret in an
undisclosed location after saying for
years that they just wanted to move move
it to a museum what they forgot to
mention is that the museum they move it
to is then going to take it and destroy
it now they won't even say what state uh
this this destruction occurred in but
the leftist who demolished Le statute
made sure to release a video of it
happening here it is
[Music]
watch
okay so they not only removed the statue
they not only destroyed it but they
melted it and took a video of it and
made sure to publish the video they gave
an inanimate statue of a Civil War
General the Terminator treatment they
melted it down and filmed it now why did
they do that exactly it it wasn't to
make the area safer for anyone in fact
just a few days ago black male was
murdered by another black male a short
distance from where the statue used to
be so it doesn't seem like the area is
now suddenly safer so what's the real
purpose of all this well here's one big
clue all those images of of the statue
being melted down were accompanied by a
lot of gloating The Washington Post for
example spoke to the executive director
of Charlottesville Black History Museum
who said quote well they can't put
Humpty Dumpty back together again that's
according to Andrea Douglas the museum
is Museum's executive director as she
watched pieces of oxidized metal descend
into the furnace uh there will be no
tape for that she says the post went on
to interview another U UVA activist
behind this destruction who said quote
Jalan Schmidt uh who this is reading now
from the article Jalan Schmidt who
directs the memory project at uva's K
Institute of democracy said she felt
like she was preparing for an execution
of sorts like if there's a rabid dog in
the neighborhood that's been hurting
people and it needs to be euthanized she
said Schmid also said quote we want to
transform it into a piece of art that
Community can be proud of and gather
around and not feel excluded or
intimidated yes because of course when
you euthanize a rabid dog you put it in
a furnace and everyone gathers around
and celebrates it they won't be
intimidated
anymore okay what kind of dog euthanasia
has this person been a part
of but it all makes perfect sense right
turning the Lee statue into an inclusive
art display it's not a humiliation
ritual at all we're supposed to believe
we're also supposed to believe that the
statue was hurting people well how was
it hurting people what was it doing to
them was it coming alive like Night at
the Museum and assaulting innocent
civilians in the middle of the night
what kind of damage was it
causing and and why didn't anyone ever
notice this damage or mention it for the
first eight or nine Decades of the
statue's
existence why are people in the
2020s more hurt by Civil War memorials
than people who lived closer to the
Civil War
were okay how did the wounds of the
Civil War become fresher over time how
is some 20s something year old in the
year
2023 uh how is it that that that for
them it's like too soon for the Civil we
can't have Civil War acknowledgement
anywhere it's too
soon and yet it wasn't in the 1930s or
40s or 50s or 60s or 70s or 80s or
90s none of this makes any sense Until
you realize that the campaign to tear
down Confederate statues was always from
the very beginning a proxy in the
overall war on American history they
just C be honest about it because they
they're never honest about anything and
all the deception is necessary in this
case because these activists have much
bigger plans they never plan to stop
with melting down the Roberty Lee statue
and they haven't indeed the Lee statue
is far from the only statue that's been
destroyed of course or essentially
destroyed in recent years according to
an investigation from the Madrid
newspaper El PES the city of Richmond
maintains a secret open a graveyard for
statues that were toppled in 2020 and
these statues are disassembled and
thrown into storage a lot of contractors
apparently passed on these disassembly
gigs for obvious reasons but eventually
Democrats in the state landed on a guy
named Devin Henry who uh who will is
willing to destroy them quoting from the
investigation Henry estimates that he
has dismantled 24 structures between
Richmond and Charlottesville the latter
is home to the University of Virginia
and is one of the cities that
acknowledged historical pain and chose
to meltdown and reuse the materials now
they destroyed pretty much uh every
statue remotely associated with the
Confederacy that includes a monument to
Stonewall Jackson Who likely was a hero
of the Mexican-American War
widely regarded as one of the best
military commanders in history de D
Henry also dismantled a conf monument to
the confederate general AP Hill who also
distinguished himself in the war with
Mexico as ELP reports the statue of hill
now has its head quote dishonorably
stuck in a tire waiting to be wrapped up
in white plastic all this to say they're
not putting any of these statues in
museums the mum Gambit was always a lie
something that only the most gullible
among us could have ever fallen for and
sadly there are a lot of gullible people
among us now that said there's maybe one
exception the Jefferson Davis statue
post BLM riots uh was taken down and and
was displayed in the Valentine Museum in
Richmond and this is how it's presented
you can see the picture here uh toppled
desecrated and covered in graffiti in
the
museum there are many more examples but
you get the point there was never any
intention to memorialize history here
leftists are doing something to leaders
of the Confederate that they won't even
do to Nazis okay they're erasing them
completely I mean you could still walk
into the World War II Museum and see
Nazi artifacts if you want posters Flags
Weaponry even you know Nazi games board
games but they don't want you seeing any
relics of the Confederacy under any
circumstance whether it's in a museum or
not in fact even if you agree with
removing the leas statue in
Charlottesville which I don't but even
if you do you must at least acknowledge
that it is a historic artifact it's
literally registered as one all of the
controversy over it just makes it more
historically
significant so there's no valid reason
to destroy it you are literally
destroying history when you destroy it
and the destruction is a gratuitous act
that can only be meant to send an
ideological and political
message and this goes well beyond the
Confederacy that's why the mob quickly
moved from the Confederacy to tearing
down statues of of pretty much any white
person
who happened to be born prior to the
20th century even Teddy Roosevelt fell
victim what this tells us is that
leftists are preoccupied above all with
erasing the history and traditions of
this country it's about power it's about
dominating and humiliating those that
they identify as the enemy and in large
part they are
succeeding we should remember that we're
in this situation now because
Republicans across the country including
in Washington people calling themselves
conservatives that is the people who are
supposed to be conserving things like
history let it happen they were too
afraid of being called racist to say
anything about it they were too weak to
stand up to this cultural vandalism when
it took
root and they're still too weak to stand
up for it or to it if Republicans had
any moral fortitude whatsoever they
would respond to the destruction of the
Lee statue by painting over every George
Floyd mural and tearing down and
destroying every single one of his
grotesque disgusting monuments if Robert
E le doesn't deserve to be honored then
a violent drug addict who who robbed
women and ripped off convenience stores
certainly doesn't pass
muster so throw his bust and golden
coffins in in in the furnace as
well but that won't happen of course
because we've come a very long way since
Eisenhower unfortunately we're heading
in the wrong
direction and frankly at this point it
probably won't be long until
Eisenhower's Memorial is melted down too
especially after they see that video but
turn it into an inclusive art display
another display of inclusivity that
excludes everyone who disagrees with
them that is the left's goal after all
it's always been their goal and if we
keep electing politicians who are too
afraid to say so then ultimately they
will achieve it hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there